hey I was gonna Breslin is Peter Pan
welcome back to quantum break we're
stuck in time okay what happened now
we're stuck in somewhere else let's just
go here yes
what an interesting start of like a yeah
the noises [ __ ] Doris in this game man
all I had to do was make it to the
garage yeah you wanna simple simple why
do I have the gun in my hand you know
shits about to happen surprise
[ __ ]
ha ha ha ha ha isn't he supposed to be
locked up that's cute
surprise [ __ ] oh oh hey look at
that hey I got a shield Freddy [ __ ] yo
hey how you doing oh [ __ ] look at that
[ __ ] headshot where are they hey ha
ha ha you just say you're out
well how couldn't feared here so am i
[ __ ] look at the bullet oh that's cool
it's so fun to [ __ ] around man I love it
this weapon is my favorite listen is it
here hey Oh someone means business oh
[ __ ] skills me
yep you lost your [ __ ] head jay says
talk about I'll be taking this okay
let's try that again
Hey no surprises Seth I got that device
for you but dr. Emeril's at the party no
Beth yeah
save me a cocktail wienie I'll make my
what's all with the cocktail weenies Hey
what's the [ __ ] is wrong with you this
is my new truck goodbye goodbye anyone
else
surprised what are you doing there Betty
oh oh oh and let's go in here
what's going on Oh God we're stuck again
I could see the mansion where the gala
was whoa I had to find a way to get dope
[ __ ] coal way oh god what just
happened I could see the energy field of
another monarch Ron yeah dream of ours
Hey
what I thought I had to reverse back in
time again I thought I could make the
jump thought it was some kind of
superhero oh I couldn't make the gem
what the [ __ ] what an [ __ ] why did he
do what what what what is that sound I
have it what there's too many what's
going on right now and I don't like it
Jesus Jack you're supposed to enroll Hey
look at that be careful Cronin dampeners
take away time powers I'll come on give
me back my powers mate hey buddy how you
doing
yeah you like that yeah yeah you like
this ad set babe oh oh hey going through
where we Hey see and the other side babe
hi buddy how you doing that hi how's
that going
that's gonna hurt a little bit tomorrow
isn't it don't worry about it don't
worry about it I know what I'm doing
I know what I'm doing don't worry about
it yes Ernest all right now we can play
game all right all right
what the [ __ ] did you come from oh [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] that's awesome I'm turning
this [ __ ] off this [ __ ] ends now
okay we're back in action baby we got
the cool moves hey you how you doing
buddy yes fly for me flap on me baby
oh yes yes oh god yes yes oh oh oh oh oh
surprise oh oh that was [ __ ] awesome
so it is sober baby you were headed for
the party yes
what was your plan odd party I need
obvious name for my stutter in the
demonic found out I was coming can I go
out no I don't know where to go now
ah here it is um no okay uh or that this
truck better not [ __ ] move I swear to
God
Thanks truck what hey what what I say
what I say what I say
I guess don't mind me carrying a bunch
of whip a weapons I'm just gonna go to
the party looking sharp filling sharp
look at the fireworks wow that's so
pretty
that should be here somewhere are you
German no one is looking at the
fireworks Green speech had been a
success the world was falling apart the
wine and cheese crowd was enjoying their
little goddamn soiree
okay I like this hello hello hello
Aloha all right okay there's Oh always
the mouth open in it hey there hey I'm
Batman it's okay it's me Jesus
yeah I've done it a couple of times
these people have no idea a positive
amusement park yeah well on our desk I
think my covers gonna last
yeah well I don't think we do much good
for this part anyway
okay doctor and we're all somewhere
inside the mansion let's go grab her
head of lock I'm getting out before
anybody knows all right okay
lead the way yes baby what's our plan
once we great yeah what's the plane boat
dock right I said mission okay you make
that work
it's with all the paintings
[ __ ] drone what about it wrong place
wrong time
what does that mean Jack dr. M rolls in
there need to get her out before time
kicks back really come on name whatever
I'm not here to save other people's
lives make your way to Sofia a shouldn't
wait let's go get dr. okay God Jesus
listen I was here before you were
but if ffff ffff better better oh my god
this is the trailer you hear Jack Joyce
you're here did you yes no but you're
coming with us we need your ass come on
have some fun
always wanted to do that to just jump
from an explosion right there oh how
convenient now we're going on a boat
ride baby
what the [ __ ] just happened there what
the [ __ ] was that
yeah let me do all the [ __ ] artwork
while you're being bent alright
I'm advancing better better better
better better better better better baby
we chill ah shoot ah shoot yeah you got
a visual
where's your visual now [ __ ] is there
anyone in here perhaps oh hey buddy how
you doing buddy
now I did it need to open that gate okay
I can do that I'm sure it's not in here
at ah you're clear go just go
no just just go to all this trouble to
grab just go Beth I'm counting on you to
just I'll make my own way out yeah have
fun on the yacht my plan was simple well
I get to sprayed with bullets fight my
way through anything Marek would throw
at me and then steal a car drive it back
to the swimming pool we'll see how it
shakes out all right well let's see how
it shakes out
I must shake it out you know what I mean
that's what I do oh god there's a lot of
them this time hi dot
ah right in the back you shot me right
in the back stop shooting me right in
the back yes yes shoot him in the ass
got him I've got another one does he not
know where I am
oh he does ha ha ha we're that's talking
I want the best in doctor and we're all
clear it was time for me to get gone
it's time for me to get gone baby I need
wheels
any wheels buddy yes I'm just repeating
what he says [ __ ] you okay we're begun
getting whoa you crazy jack you [ __ ]
crazy
hi I'll pay the Lambo please I love my
car feet this is why I never trust
valets people like you jack
think it's just some tree you can pluck
apples
listen Jack you're a thief
oh good thing we bought the [ __ ] pan
cert version Jesus okay all right cool
end of fact meet end of act 3 [ __ ]
end of act 3 yeah cool alright we're
gonna keep going into act 4 right away
guess this is pretty short okay cool I'm
enjoying this I really am I hope you
bros enjoy as well
it's cool cool [ __ ] Junction three Sofie
and [ __ ] I just hope we don't have to
watch a movie this please no moving
growing inside me he's becoming evil
isn't he
I've been fighting it for six hard years
dr. Almirall was developing a cure for
the Cronin syndrome she was the only one
who could administer the treatments that
kept my sickness at bay oh and Jack had
taken her away from me yeah but she was
about to die anyway he was about to kill
her oh he's pissed how's it possible he
managed to take her Paul does your
illness talking I'm on your side
ah easy yo oh they took her without
Sofia there's no chance of a cure we did
all we could but there are forces within
monarch working against you when I
believe Burke was just the tip of the
iceberg it wasn't just Joyce that did
this sir we've recovered dr. Sarah uh he
killed everyone look I'll be right there
I want to go over Sofia's figures if
she's right the fracture is escalating a
lot faster than we anticipated you know
the future
doctor emerald doesn't is the lifeboat
even in a viable state for activation
she's trying to convince you of the
schedules wrong why did you rush this to
make a mistake the people opposing you
she could be one of them okay she isn't
sounds like we have to make another
decision the entire plan on there I'm
Pro you hold off on activation Paul let
me clean house before this gets
completely out of hand I'm so confused
how do you want to proceed yeah all
right let me let me decide how about
that somebody was working against me
somebody close Martin hatch Sofia Amaral
I could only trust one of them I don't
agree with the fact that they use a
separate character that you don't play
asked to make the decisions what's nice
about the decisions that you feel like
you're part of it now I just feel like
I'm making a decision for someone else
but let's see what we're doing anyway
immediately
Warren Ange Martin had been my closest
advisor for years I began to wonder if
that had been a mistake Sophia's loyal
she's always been loyal I don't think
she's lying I don't think we can trust
her when she looked at the
countermeasure like she's seen it before
she knows what it does Sophia's research
had saved my life loyalty doesn't run
any deeper okay let's watch hatch all
right never wrong
let's go fix Dungey I said I'll try
evidence was mounting against Sophia I
couldn't simply ignore it despite
everything we had been through but she
knew you'd never make it without the
students then she took the boy if she
turned against me with what she knew the
damage could be immeasurable uh it seems
too cliche that hatch is the bad guys
I'm gonna go with hat right we need to
stick to the original plan but there's
Sophia's date is good or not
we can't deviate from that clearly we
have been compromised put a team
together find out who she's been working
with actually I've already guts it to
know that fraud they just pulled this
from the security feed
my god it's her whoo yeah whoo
her Martin bad she's one of our
employees how the hell we got too big
for you to screen everybody personally
would be never not be on her until now
Beth Wilder she's one of our upper dupes
we've already got a kill team after but
we won't be able to kill her
not yet how can she be working with Jack
how does she even know him I told you
Paul we can't trust her in people who
knows how deep this goes
find out
Beth Wilder it was the first time I'd
heard her name but she had been there in
the past why is her mouth not open fest
started what really she'd been there the
whole time working against me from the
inside the only one that is ever present
oh [ __ ] it what are you gonna do now we
get a recap from last episodes Sophia
you shouldn't worry so much [ __ ] let's
ride a chair that chair didn't weight
anything something in there that I need
the lifeboat protocol poles a very
dangerous man and things only get worse
if you continue subject
what is it that you're so threatened by
Martin do I look threatened yeah do I do
you [ __ ] see me [ __ ]
this is doctor Ambrose report this
stutters they're they're increasing in
frequency what is that Crone undisrupted
life-form extremely hostile
it's dr. camp yeah that was [ __ ]
weird
hahaha what the [ __ ] I don't understand
why would thug and ten sorry that just
looked funny alright well there we go
let's watch another TV show episode
together
sorry okay cool
poor guy you just got played put on the
yep
what is with his eyedrops
he is an a I I know it that skull is way
too shiny man why are we why are you
running man you have a great job give
that all up just like that because he
saw a doctor Kim listen Mon our car
super nice I'm sure they're a great
corporation to work with you're such a
mean look they throw a great party I
don't know I don't even know what the
lifeboat protocol is it's a sanctuary
designed to shelter list of products
essential personnel man the last lever
the storm until they can develop a
solution
essential personnel so that means it I'd
be on that list right not in the
porcelains lead you wouldn't
he's failed to see the value in his old
people too consumed with grand ideals
and delusions you know what I find to be
the most terrifying notion on this
planet
the idea of God simply the idea a being
with that much power the ability to take
and give so freedom that kind of control
but should be feared not worshipped yet
people believe in it just as people
believe in Paul serene see what's so
scary about God isn't his control
brother if he ever lost it that didn't
make anything Paul serines become
unhinged truly he's triggered a
catastrophe way yet all right is the
chance to fix it but he's choosing not
to he's choosing to let things end name
the time and this is where we come in we
risk too much leaving the keys to the
kingdom and one man's hands
we need insurance there's something
called the CFR it's a crucial key to our
survival and must remain safe but as
long as Paul is the only one with access
to it it isn't
with access to the c4 I would take over
get monarch back on track and once I do
restructuring would be an order Charlie
restructuring that would see you as my
right hand I'd be on the last absolutely
now I need to go back to monarch and
that sort of privilege isolation you can
only be done from the inside feel so
awkward being here I'm watching a TV
show with you bros it's kind of weird
yeah that's the face you make for the
island or you like something but the
pump house on the west side is an old
supply tunnel that runs belief Bay no
one knows about it
you'll go unseen time is of the essence
charlie better get to it
you think what a dumb [ __ ]
come on to Davis sir head to the
perimeter lab we're moving forward I'm
gonna get [ __ ] [ __ ] the frequency of
the stars is still unpredictable but
they're persistently erratic but I need
certainty if I initiate the protocol
there's no going back yes the serene
something like this there is no
certainty we've never dealt with it
before how long we've been running dr.
Amaral simulations it's hard to say
without her to confirm but just give me
a time the joist field could collapse
within eight hours mr. Suri if you're
going to proceed now would be the time
to decide
later I wish I could use that [ __ ]
Charlie yeah hey bud were you going
you're right
times ending just like you said [ __ ]
thing for tikal it's a place they built
it to protect people from the fracture
the only problem is is that is there's a
list and anyone who's not on it it's
pretty much [ __ ] but if we make it
back at the mainland I can get us on the
list all of this entire island is on
lockdown how we're gonna do that Charlie
there's a tunnel all right if you are
lying to me this time still tired [ __ ] I
don't know why you're doing this I don't
have to put your name on [ __ ]
[ __ ] what'd you do - he's fine
I'm gonna tell you why you're gonna put
me on that list I got a pregnant wife at
home and she's the only thing that I'm
thinking about right now so if you get
in the way of me protecting her I swear
to [ __ ] god next time
you will not catch a breath
what a [ __ ] put me on the list man
leads away
man I'm so confused with the timelines
like if if this is just 17 hours that
sends you know we started the game how
is that guy Paul and he's lived 17 years
I don't understand I think it would all
make sense in the end guys
right now we're watching these guys go
through a tunnel and it is pretty
exciting
dr. Kim's land dr. Kim is chillin with
Siri sliding into her dance of course
named Mars a stupid robot five minutes
out mister - couldn't they ever just
open for him if they're already in
anyway just playing when we came in
it's the audiotapes still playing ha ha
ha ha the audio tape we started that's
awesome
I wanted the if they don't have it if
you don't click on it that's so funny
it's very subtle hint of humor
throughout this set this game I noticed
someone was clearly like we need we need
some jokes I've come to free you my
friend trying to sneak him in
imprisonment some Siddeley
it's time for you to rejoin the others
to attune to the infinite yes set him
three at for a free once he looks so
happy I've never seen him so happy what
the [ __ ]
so creepy
oh [ __ ]
just like that cool guys don't look at
explosions they blow [ __ ] up and just
walk away half our lunch here what three
mom yeah just three months get out of
here congratulations
oh yeah he's still wearing the thing
I would punch him in the deck please do
please stick something up his ass at
least like come on
ah come on
we're under the bay we should probably
get out of the town oh I am clearly not
Liam dude
now that wasn't clear
oh you guys come [ __ ] down doesn't
have a gun
look at them run they're so cute hey
look you guys made it you didn't get wet
you okay yeah you care yeah I'm good
Wendy Oh what do you understand Wow hey
no no no hey I'm gonna call Dave I match
this guy what guy
yeah who's she she's growing on
scientist she's important we have to get
her back to monarch right away please
well done it just [ __ ] shooting that
guy look at you now yeah
you kill my BFF Yonah Yonah
gotta listen hey you killed up [ __ ] hey
I didn't know they were gonna kill him
what was I supposed to do huh you led me
on I mean you kidnapped me there you
Charlie be stealing this car skip the
[ __ ] out of here don't you're gonna need
me I got what I needed out of you Oh
getting used to it why don't you open
your eyes the world is about to end I'm
trying to do something yeah you're a
real hero [ __ ] you
what maybe he's not dead maybe he's just
sleeping oh god I just realized I gotta
go nurse huh
I'm back but it's been probably a second
for you [ __ ] that guy is bald he's
definitely not dead he's wearing a suit
I'm really gonna like killing her wife
oh he's like you did not just say that I
was wearing a suit
nice nice way to go bro Wow I really
thought he was dead
I am shocked that he made it I
sympathize with his wife and his unborn
child I really hope he lives fell for
the old knife in a boot trick good ol
knife in a boot trick he could have used
that knife before when he was impressing
I guess but yes you don't need you need
that when you have a chair you can kick
at people I get his other gun you can
akimbo that [ __ ]
shoot him in the dick there it is good
job that's what you gotta do you gotta
shoot him in a day
commander I'm so childish Jesus Christ
Davis and esteem they're all good men
monix finest he looks so unreal and a
why
Oh what about my treatments I'm afraid
soon you know what this means you don't
know for sure hey don't take it out on
the chairs the chair shouldn't do
anything he wants me to become he wants
me to suffer until the end joys and
wildly but what was troubling me is who
got them in the Kim's lab Oh while she
was thought to be missing she knew but
your treatments will kept chute of the
complexities of your illness but it was
actually not Harry was hands she created
him that she took him away I need her
found now
the wood would you like done with I'll
decide that when she's brought to me
he is betraying you why am i
sympathizing with this guy he I don't
understand
that was a little too close thought we
were gonna kiss for a second Jesus
Christ is awkward
how long is his TV show okay alright
we're still watching all right
I need a hospital awkward Liam hey pal
was that the dentist and someone just
shot me I was just doing your girl here
how concerned about you we've been
Emily we need to go go
what's the rush
shoot him in the dick
let's go
Oh Oh not at a hospital okay Jesus
Christ what is what am I looking at Oh
Lauren make me motion sick got him he's
like I know karate oh [ __ ] hate to be
that guy [ __ ] I'm not paid for this oh
really he's gonna murder him in front of
everyone that's cool that's cool no one
seems to care really got his new boots
on and everything
you hold you hold even though they let
go you hold [ __ ] amateur
it's like he never killed anyone before
what a [ __ ] that's a little awkward uh
he's my boyfriend I don't know how to
tell you I'm gonna give me the keys give
me the keys please
yeah this is not a way it's not tell you
I never felt good doing this I I never I
never felt good
upon where I can't me think I knew how
to do uh-huh the crazy sack I couldn't I
couldn't find anything you couldn't find
he doing hung in there like that like I
found that useful and they put me to
work
I swear to God I could I couldn't say I
couldn't stand being alone so every
Tuesdays and Wednesdays up with I walk
down the street because there was only
two nights at the bartenders cuz she
wasn't at school and I told myself every
night to ask you it took me [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's more like if they gave me structure
and you gave me purpose did this to
protect you did this to protect what is
it talking about
listen to me
something terrible is coming I will
explain to you on Winkle we have to move
right now look at the rain if you were
just like me if you will just let me
protect you
my son hey she can protect herself she's
a doctor all right I'm sure she's fine
without you
you [ __ ] weird psychopath [ __ ]
weird ass hugger
it was almost awkward scene in my life
Jesus did you feel it too man
it is kind of a nice change of pace to
watch the movies you know it makes you
excited about coming back into the game
you don't look too good man wasn't her
it was that guy oh he's seeing alternate
universes his tongue is so [ __ ] weird
he keeps doing the telling thing it's
like I am an actor
yeah it's Pierce oh god what 11 so I
have some information about mourn hatch
I want him apprehended immediately
you're right there you're right they
make it's over end of this episode will
only empathize 3 god I hope you enjoyed
this episode if you did give it a thumbs
up I really enjoyed this game really
cool and I would love to do more so if
you wanted to see more let me know in
the comments and I'll see you bros in
the next one as always stay awesome
press now let's rock oh oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
dammit